hey guys it's that time of the year
again
everyone is getting ready to throughout
the past year and start planning for an
even better year
and one of the most popular ways to get
ready for the new year is by creating
new year's resolutions
this video brings to you a few
achievable resolutions that will help
you with your overall development
without further ado let's begin
first up focus on your physical fitness
work from home has become the new normal
and according to experts this may not
change in the near future moving our
bodies has become crucial focus on your
physical fitness find the type of
workout that best suits you and stick to
it
it could be a 20 minutes high intensity
workout yoga or a quick run in the
neighborhood it is also vital to
maintain a healthy cut incorporate
nutrient-rich foods into your diet and
cut back on fast food but the most
underrated practice is getting an 8 hour
sleep avoid tech gadgets at night and
concentrate on getting a good night's
sleep for better immunity
prioritize mental health it's easy to
get caught up in day to day activities
often we don't get time to resolve
matters of the mind practice meditation
for 15 minutes every day and maintain a
journal to write down your thoughts
reach out to your friends and family on
a regular basis to discuss your issues
lastly and we cannot stress this enough
seek professional help
set short-term achievable goals prepare
a daily and weekly plan write down
achievable goals these goals could
include organizing your workstation or
cleaning the car short term goals help
with better time management kill
procrastination and motivate you to take
up more tasks and finish them
do your finances
it can be overwhelming to manage your
money it's important to have an idea of
your earnings expenses and savings
here are some tips you could follow for
a better financial situation
spend less on unnecessary things this
could include subscriptions to various
odt platforms and purchasing items that
don't add value to your life
create a personal budget tracking your
spending can be a useful tool to help
you understand where your money goes
each month
a clear budget can help you set
guidelines for what you can afford to
spend and help you identify areas where
you could cut back
read more books
this is one of the widely made
resolutions but sticking to it is
difficult
set a time out every day to read this
could be right before you sleep or even
after your lunch break if you have a
competitive streak take up reading
challenges or join a book club listen to
audiobooks on your daily commute or
while doing your mundane chores
research about a topic that interests
you it's very easy to get new
information be it while watching the
news a tv show or reading a book if it
catches your attention do your research
there are thousands of resources
available on the internet today
read up and watch youtube videos or
documentaries on the subject
make it a daily habit to learn something
new never lose your curious mind
make time for recreation the hustle life
is overrated make time for your personal
growth hone your skills and talents make
time on weekly basis to indulge in good
food music arts dance and literature
find what you love and make time for it
take a short trip regularly
try adventure sports hike up the
mountains go camping it all depends on
how well you manage your time
charity and volunteering
the societal benefits of volunteering
are obvious but research has shown that
volunteering can also offer many
benefits for your personal well-being
donate consistently mentor the youth
volunteer at the animal shelter clean up
the neighborhood imbibing these
qualities will help you grow and do good
for society
learn new
skills learn new skills that will help
with personality development
these skills could be public speaking
cooking driving etc
you could also take up courses that can
help your professional life
there are several online certification
programs that you could enroll in
simplylearn is an online learning
platform that offers a plethora of
courses for full stack development cloud
computing cyber security and digital
marketing among others check out the
website and pick the course that suits
your requirements
don't be hard on yourself
it's only human nature to fall off the
wagon
you may have rough days where you can't
follow your set schedule it's crucial to
not be hard on yourself
take some rest but also be accountable
for your actions
these were some simple yet achievable
goals for 2022
if you haven't made a list now is the
right time
good luck this year remember you can
achieve anything you put your mind to
for more interesting content from us
stay tuned to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here